[Music]
the time has come our costume designer
Scott chronic and his partner David Gore
shine are gonna get married right here
right now on our stage I will perform
the ceremony Scott and David have
requested the Hopa which is the
traditional Jewish wedding canopy and we
have friends and family of David right
here and we have friends and family of
Scott right over here and they're not
speaking for some reason you settle down
David will you join me in the hook-up
please
[Music]
now when we asked Scott if there was
someone special he'd like to walk him
down the aisle he gave us the name of
his favorite celebrity were happy he was
able to join us please welcome the host
of Bravo's watch what happens live Andy
Cohen
very cool everybody all right you want
to take your place we're all set there
you go there you go all right Jimmy we
have a little wedding music please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is fantastic
you've been with me for years you never
designed me anything like this all right
this is for real we are gathered here
today in this beautiful place do witness
the joining of two lives David do you
have anything you'd like to say to Scott
I do Scott you are my everything you're
my love
and I hope everyone in the world can be
lucky enough to find the love that we
share anyone in the world would be happy
to wear one of your designs but no one
is possibly happier than I am to wear
your ring and to put this ring on your
finger I love you so much you are my
everything
Scott David I have only one vow for you
I vowed to fill your every day with so
much love and cameras are no cameras
David I'm here today and I am yours
forever
all right
Jewish tradition now calls for the groom
to break a glass we have two grooms so
that means two glasses Andy
[Applause]
all right this is it by the power vested
in me by the state of New York and the
Universal Life Church monastery I now
pronounce you husband and husband you
can kiss
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Scott and David are married
into the sunset with a little help from
our good friend Ted Turner taken away
hey Ted
[Applause]
you